hello welcome back to GameSpot presents
the mix live from GDC 2015 we've only
got a couple of games left to play and
the next one up it seasons after four
I'm delighted to be joined by Ben and
Guillaume you guys have come all the way
from Montpellier yeah congratulations
welcome you welcome to San Francisco
appreciate it and this game looks
gorgeous I remember seeing it I think
was that the gamescom you guys really
sure last year yeah how long you guys
been working on this so so far we're
looking working on this for a year
yeah I think I don't get there yeah
excellent how big is the team we are six
people now so there is benoît me we are
programmer mmm
in the there is zero the artist so you
make user just one artist yeah one guy I
was doing good work so is more like a
concept office so we like making
concepts yeah so in the game we try to
we use as maximum as you can access
concept so we'll talk about that later
but then there's William or the designer
and the paper man the paperwork company
and but you guys got to come out here
and enjoy the wonders of actually
showing off the game yeah we figured it
was better to take both the programmers
out of production for a week you know if
there's any problem defect it's like
perfect and I think you just keep
drawing yours finally yeah and pay yeah
exactly
let's jump right in yeah I just want to
see it so there is a also young when the
prison mmm
with making the music how wonderful yes
and also yeah fantastic school was
looking around the music for our game so
the first game we we raised was black
that matter you would see anything
premiere would excel and it was more
like a puzzle platformer mmm then to
attend Koh it was like the spiritual
sequel to the first one yeah yeah and
then it's complete difference it's not
footballer game anymore it's more like
expression game so you play as a fox
you can't die in the game you can you
you can die so you have to to explore
the nature of the game
stammers again and you control these
facts it's absolute like it's just it's
one of these games that like it's this
and Ori I remember were the ones during
the summer or in the black fires that
really jumped out is just like we were
study inspired by really you go to play
the game I guess he is ready coming soon
but this looks incredible and
considering it's a team of like six
people one artist as well like yeah so
we took the the philosophy of the UBS
framework because been working right on
it and then oh yeah I guess yeah so we
are we're using the the same philosophy
to build the game so we part of the the
the the beaker and viola background or
environment is is reusable so we can
like your I don't know if you see that
the video of the you be out from work so
it's very clever system oh yes you draw
a vectorial shape and then you you have
an automatic drew so it really I guess
it helps you be the team like you were
to go yeah develop quickly like it's
like stretchable reusable content dot
yeah so here for example with the ID we
don't like game with too many much too
much tutorial in it yeah we prefer let
the player Lorelei playing yeah and and
right here for example I'm stuck on the
right so I can see if I can go ahead and
I just can jump on this tree but that's
it yeah and this kind of green thing is
attracting so I'm just jumping any
action it was a jumper and then also the
propagation of some substance I don't
know what it is I mean let's follow is
this track so the white intimate
actually the camera is probably like
quite a close it's not like yeah we try
to to establish a relationship between
the player and the Fox
so here the the this kind of systems is
spreading again so let's let's see where
we good
so we already try to to teach the player
not to have text in the game so it's not
the purpose it's pure full screen no
head
you know device system here illusion so
we try to to keep it that way for now
and then
if I can put it here and stick again so
it's a game where I just take a lot of
time and the facts I can jump em you see
you can yep so for you for now it's
really work in progress
yeah yeah hey Stevie see that's what we
used and then there is a the key feature
of the game you can switch seasons at
wheel okay so for example I can switch
to Indra Wow okay which back okay um and
then back to winter Jesus so you have
unlimited power to change the seasons
yeah everywhere with time so at the
beginning of the game you will not have
the full yes Four Seasons right there
because it would be not so challenging
yeah yeah and we almost like too much
information it does yeah the bear as
well exactly
so if yeah he's sitting he's going oh
that's so man let's play you guys did a
good job of making a super cute fox I
don't try to write that's like that's
like the bed like yeah yeah Raymond is a
good example of good idle animations for
for yeah also mean so much animation in
your own under it like that that's the
actual hundred or even revaluation just
for Raymond so I thought I don't think
you manager make something which just
looks beautiful and I like you know just
sitting on his back hind legs that's I'm
a cat owner so I didn't appreciate for
example is this vegetation leaves in
winter so it's not obvious because the
feedback I'm not writing it if I open it
we it will on all excellent and now I
can go on it and then go continue on
your merry way if I switch season back
you will see that it will retract
gorgeous so you you have to understand
all the ecosystem work to progress in
the game that also means that you know
you're saving time which are artists by
having the sort of like you be are
having the sort of lab system that
allows you guys to like build with with
the art but then you're also creating
like exactly so much art for every level
for Russian of them so yeah we save time
but with the the whole tool is made for
organic stuff very reusable but then
yeah we kind of sort out ourselves in
the new way for season time hidden
so overall we we aim for kind of a short
intense experiences that gonna be a huge
company so we rather have lots of very
memorable moments very very nice art
instead of spreading it for stretches
anyway we don't have the resources
yes o3o there is a bigger Bureau
based on my myface he looks like me yeah
that's true yeah so it's you guys yeah
we've got some mocap system and supposed
to be some of the gradient of the season
okay so he is not supposed to be tae -
like I like that but it was just for a
sample - to let the player understand
what you have to do so and leave the the
guy so if I do if I spread the substance
oh yeah it will kind of energizing yeah
so now is the music was beautiful as
well in the trailers I've seen you guys
have like a did you record with a string
yeah there's something show you some no
real gauge just alright doctor oh yeah
fantastic please do so then we can climb
on on stuff like this that for example
there is another ingredient here it's a
mushroom Ohio in winter is is its
problem that transition is fantastic
yeah we would like to try to have more
of them because it is always the same
but and then if I jump on Sean show more
seasons on that yeah oh yeah on this on
this mushroom it would be well so again
I guess I got to understand and all the
mushroom works mmm so yeah the down mode
on one season 10 Wow still in the making
for the colors and stuff like that way
you can you can switch at Gamescom we
only add the autumn and winter
oh really which are like that head of
the the central elements of this map but
we have to put yet but just to show ya
since then we made a two extra seasons
but they're not as balanced it's a good
thing there's not a fifth season they
said yeah take a long long grain because
it would be super hard so yeah yeah in
this part you have to
to find your way to to get some stuff we
didn't see it's a it's a jellyfish it's
some spiritual stuff right there so you
in the game you have to find out what
the jellyfish is good for she will help
you solve do you take her along for yeah
of the game like as a Kenyan kind of
almost yeah and for example in winter
she's frozen so she will not follow you
have to take care of that she's
shivering yeah for jellyfish
yes we're know she's out of water sorry
yeah poor thing it's pretty fish I think
we can move on to these this jellyfish
is some kind of key to unlock doors or
stuff like that so we we try to make
simple system but item well and let the
player understand what instead of like
having some sort of like inventory thing
or like we don't want on virtually for
example the the head force and switching
seasons will be around you yeah so for
now it's time probably it was like zero
in terms of like head exactly it is not
much very minimalist and very intimate
like you're saying like it's yeah it's
direct so for example we were talking
about the music so yum than the
Christian or musician record it with a
quadrat of string so the Darby string
instrument in the choir and that will it
will be like in Tomb Raider when you
discover a thing there will be music it
will be not music all the time yeah okay
silent to punctuate any reaction because
then the music has sort of more weight
down the time you will have the sound of
nature obviously for yeah for what's
interesting is for previous games he
didn't did more like chiptune tracks
yeah and he plays a lot with that even
makes his own albums and it is more
leaning in that direction but by my
education is actually a cellist oh
really
so um so this is a this is big this big
moment yeah it's like magnum opus or
whatever it still has lots of ideas of
how to use surprising elements for you
like maybe some some of the sound
effects will be actually key you know
no for example when the vegetation on or
maybe she will make some songs to play
notes and that's kind of guy what do you
think like it is a bad because we're
seeing so many of these games comment of
like like France the center it's like
between the Raymond stuff and obviously
Ruby are there was a lot of people who
were like technically like educated and
that type of design but like things like
child of light last year as well was
again another kind of very traditional
in one way because it was very gamey
game lots of yak an excessive like
skills and progression but again it
liked slow then that pace and made it
like much more you know there's not many
studios especially of your size that
would go to the bother of like recording
actual string quartets to put into the
game do you think there's something
about like for the French mentality of
design that like is coming through in
your game I think it's a matter of focus
well we're so small that we just have to
pick our battle and yeah so like we're
not gonna be able to edit huge amounts
of sound effects and stuff you know
maybe we'll have these nice tracks and
use them wisely and yeah same for
example we will have a narrator in the
game but we want we won't have dialogue
so we can have we can do some small
stuff with the editor but we can do a
whole little dialogue and cutscenes yeah
so you so presumably anything you're
doing you're you're wanting to do well
not just do a lot of it and we have to
be careful about that because then we
are prepared to make the double game
because yeah it's ambitious for six
people but we we have to take care of us
so when seasons after fall when will we
be able to play at what platforms is
angular on alt will be mid early 2016
it was like like - 15 - 16 yeah we have
to take care of what we say because we
are helped by focus I want to active on
this game so we love them there will be
no she's on that so far just be on
waiting in the back yeah I'm I'm and
Embrapa you know
sorry this is new for sprinkling some
rain because the first two games were
self-published Ohio cases before this
one it was a more ambitious one so we
yeah we really want to ambitious and we
we made PC games before and the second
game is actually no party to mobile as
well
three and two we you but that was kind
of and after and but now we want to go
console for you because this is like a
couch get me yeah this is you want to
chill with a pattern so we felt we could
make the PC version but just like barely
with our resources yeah
and now we can we can safely fifty say
okay we'll be able to do Xbox one ps4 at
certification excellent you know so
fingers crossed in 2016 will be able to
play and a whole bunch of stuff fingers
crossed
thank you so much for coming in it's
absolutely beautiful a thriving looks
and and sounds beautiful and I there's
something very interesting about having
this sort of platformer but that's a lot
more focused on a lot more intimate yeah
so I can't wait to see more with a Q on
my band thank you so much going again
just enjoy the rest of GDC I can see
what you're already in the mood for
video and Cisco you know nice work it's
offseason but don't worry about it yes
still okay I'm still off seasons season
so far yeah yeah no yeah I don't think
you'll see thank you so much for coming
really appreciate